(swooshing sound)
- YouTube what's up, so so grateful
that you clicked and you're about to watch
a new YouTube video but before you do,
212-931-5731, that is my
texting community platform.
I'm doing a lot of one-on-one
engagement in there
and also access opportunity first looks
in that environment.
212-931-5731 join it now
and now, to the video you've
been wanting to watch.
In today's climate, in society,
I promise you the following:
You wanna find a lot of negativity?
It's very easy, on the flip side
a much more unpopular opinion,
is if you wanna find a lot
of happiness and opportunity,
you can find it very easily.
You decide.
(dramatic music)
You've got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
- Gary, why don't we start
off by, why don't you tell
us a little bit about what VaynerMedia is?
- You know, obviously
you saw in the video,
I try to make it as simple as possible.
All we really are is a agency.
I think what makes us different is,
because I didn't come
from the agency landscape
and more importantly,
because I built VaynerMedia
with the intent to be a platform
for buying businesses and brands
during the next economic downturn,
it's been built very differently.
The first thing that was different
was that we have media and
creative under one house.
Not part of a holding company
where it's separate companies
but from day one, it was
built where both media
and creative sit together and the context
and the end consumer is
truly, not through reporting,
not through data but
truly at the forefront
and we think about math
and art as friction
to create diamonds, not one is
more valuable than the other.
And then really, the only
other big variable difference
is it's a dictatorship, you know?
(audience laughs)
and what I mean by that
is, I don't have a board,
I don't have a holding
co, everything wrong
at Vayner is 100% my fault
and when something's run
by an entrepreneurial operator
a lot of good can happen in growth
and a lot of growing pains
and silly young things happen
and I definitely think we're
dramatically more contemporary
than every alternative
at the global scale.
We have Singapore, London,
we have a thousand people.
It's not a small company.
I spent a lot of time
actually, strategically
making it about me, look over
here, look at this crazy guy,
so that I can operate
something that I think
is quite disruptive over
here and I'm proud of that.
But I think it's a very different shop
because it comes from a
very different agenda.
We're not held accountable
to every 90 day finance goals
and I think that has
been a massive advantage.
- Yeah, no quarterly earnings, huh?
- No and no getting on
a call with analysts
and appeasing some short-term narrative
that's an inside vigged game.
(audience laughs)
- I remember a meeting
that we had at one point
where you came to us and said,
you would bring new
channels to us, for example
and with Pinterest and you
talked to us about Pinterest
and one time you came and you said,
"You guys gotta figure out Snapchat.
"You gotta be on
Snapchat, it's the future"
and at that point, it was just something
that my kids did and I
couldn't figure it out.
What's next and what's new in that space
that we should be looking at?
- It's interesting Trish, even in that,
it's very rare, very
rare though I'm a human,
I'm sure I slip up but I would argue
if we had film of me
bringing up Snap in time
that it was more likely
that I didn't refer to it
as the future and I never predict.
I'm just completely
obsessed with right now.
What I know right this
second, as we sit here
and everybody watching around the world,
that LinkedIn and TikTok
are the two platforms
that give you organic reach.
If you do not pay media,
if you're a nobody
and you post on either one
of those two platforms,
something great can
happen that cannot happen
outside of a miracle 0.00001% chance
on Facebook, Twitter,
Instagram and YouTube.
Those things always fascinate me
because I love under-priced real estate.
If I came to somebody 25 years ago
and said there's an island
called Turks and Caicos
that I genuinely believed
more people will go to it
over the next 25 years
and we bought up property,
everybody would be happy.
So I spend all my time on two core things.
One, under-priced organic reach,
which often is more at a small,
entrepreneurial SMB level.
At the corporate level they're important
because I want companies to get the reps
of understanding the nuances
that are making this platform pop
and understanding LinkedIn
today is very different
than all of us understanding
it four years ago.
It's a completely different beast.
LinkedIn today acts much more
like Facebook did six years ago
than the LinkedIn that
we all grew up using,
which was a tool, not a content platform.
The things I'm learning on TikTok now
will matter because those
are getting instilled
into 12 and 19 year olds right now
and those will become
nuances that quite matter
in communication in three,
five, seven, nine years.
Obviously, Chase is less
likely to be obsessed
with understanding TikTok,
in comparison to Vans
or in comparison to Mattel, right?
So you think about all those things
but I don't know what's next.
What I do know is that I'm incredibly good
at understanding, as a human,
subjectively, intuitively,
of what seems to be current
and then I put a ton of
discipline and work ethic
and dollars and effort into
proving those hypotheses
to be true or false.
- So shifting a little,
if you think about,
since it's in the news
- Okay.
- Interested in your thoughts on Twitter's
recent announcement about
banning political ads,
without getting political
in our discussion but--
- I think the platforms
are making a ridiculously,
personally, I think it's smart.
I think that platform's
revenue from political ads
is not significant enough in return
for what the headlining
and positioning means to it
and all the vulnerabilities of it.
We are in a fully on-tilt,
headline reading society.
The amount of opinions in this room,
from the two of us to
everybody in this room,
to everybody who's watching,
where we have deep
convictions and thoughts,
predicated on one or two
headlines is laughable.
So A, I think it was a smart move by Jack.
I think it helps Twitter but I think they
the platforms have done
an incredibly bad job
in distinguishing what a platform is.
People are way on tilt on believing
that they're manipulating something.
Mark's opportunity when AOC asks him,
will you police this truth?
Is easily rebuttaled with,
can we have CNN and Fox do that too?
We are at a very funny place
where ask modern technologies to do things
that we don't hold traditional
technologies accountable for.
So great but I think in the
macro, they're doing a poor job.
I'm very curious what
the variable difference
is between not fact checking an ad
in a Facebook feed,
versus not checking a fact
coming out of a news anchor's
mouth on a news platform.
- Well let me push back just a little bit.
- Please, I love pushing back a bit.
- So we do a lot of work right now
looking at the impact of bots.
On escalating news on social media
in a way that if you just saw an article
in the New York Times that it might not
move at the same pace.
And how do you see bots
impacting the spread of news
and the spread of fake news, for example?
- I don't view technology any different
than I look at humans.
This is one big game of communication.
Do we have data that
shows what Carson Tucker
or Don Lemon mean when they say something?
That's my pushback, my pushback
is when are we gonna hold ourselves
accountable for the information?
Whether a bot is run to run
more ads or more potential
awareness against a headline,
or a newscaster uses an adjective in a way
that pushes that information, I genuinely
do not see the variable
difference to the end consumer.
I would argue people are
hearing what they want to hear.
I don't know, I see plenty
of things coming on Facebook
and CNN and Fox and Twitter
that I'm a big enough boy
to decipher what I want to
believe or tend to believe
or I'm curious about.
This notion that we're so helpless
that the second that we see something,
we believe it to be true,
I think it's the reverse.
I think we're justifying
what we want to be true
through the propaganda.
- So how should we then consume news
as an educated consumer and be discerning.
- By putting in the work.
You know how many people here
are gonna be keyboard warriors
about politics and not
even register to vote?
How should we do it?
The same way we do everything.
Remember when you blindly
believed everything
out of your parents mouth?
You grew up, it's time
we do that with media.
(audience applauds)
- So last year you published
the book "Crushing it"
which is a bit of an evolution
from the 2009 "Crush it"
- Thank you.
(audience laughs)
- And so, tell us about what has evolved
from a trend perspective of branding.
What's new and different now,
what's stayed the same and what has died?
- When I wrote "Crush it" in 2008
and then the book came out in '09,
the thought of building a
viable business or lifestyle
on the back of YouTube or
Twitter was a laughable event.
If you go to amazon right
now and look at the first
500 reviews of "Crush it"
that were published in 2009,
basically it's a mix of
"this guy's completely
"a snake oil salesman"
to "social media will be gone next year".
There was not a belief that
enough scale could happen
on these platforms to
create something meaningful.
So what's evolved is the
acceptance from the masses
that there is power
behind these platforms.
We've gone from 2009, where
people didn't believe me
that these platforms were powerful enough
for you to be able to make $80,000 a year
to us now feeling like we have
to break up these companies
'cause they're so powerful
in dictating our minds.
So that's changed, the
perception of the power
of social networks, which oh by the way,
are just the current state
of where our tension is
on the internet itself.
Whether this goes to AR or VR, or voice
all this is is where are
we paying attention to?
So that's the biggest change.
The things that are the same are my belief
that there's a lot of people
here in this room watching
who have a certain perspective
on how they're gonna live their life
and what is gonna bring
the most happiness to them
and I wanna continue to beat a drum
of do not underestimate
the power of this platform.
Do not underestimate what it feels like
to be desperately happy
making $103,000 a year
doing something you love,
versus being unhappy
making $197,000 a year
spending it on things
to disguise your unhappiness.
- And you do talk a lot
on your social channels
about hating your job and while obviously,
everyone here loves their job.
(audience laughs)
I mean we all go through points,
whether you're on a
non-traditional career path
like some of the influencers
that you work with
that are entrepreneurs or even a more
traditional path like the ones here.
What advice, what could we learn,
for those of us on a more traditional path
from the non-traditional
folks that you work with?
- You know it's funny, it's really hard
to ask a giraffe to be
a penguin or vice versa
and so one thing that's
become much more obvious to me
as I've gotten older is like wow,
DNA is powerful, I'm so
comfortable with "no"
and losing and fear but I'm so empathetic
to people that aren't.
I and this will surprise a lot
of you that maybe follow me,
I'm unbelievably comfortable
with aggressiveness
and candor and binary talk on stage
but one-on-one, I've really struggled
over the last 25 years as an executive
with radical candor and
shooting it straight
because I'm so optimistic and
I'm always trying to fix it
and so that's taken me a lot of work
and through that work, I'm like okay,
there's the things that come
natural and things that aren't.
If you grew up in a framework with parents
or customs that really,
desperately over valued
outside affirmation, the
opinions of your parents'
parents or siblings,
because you come from,
let's call it what it is,
an immigrant background
where there's a huge commonality there.
School, you were so
deeply bought into school
that the short term
affirmation of every 90 days
with grades and report
cards made you comfortable.
It's very hard to then go into hey,
this is what you should
learn from entrepreneur land.
Don't worry about it,
it's all gonna be fine.
That's very hard, you've
fully built yourself
as an animal to completely
value outside judgment
that is not based on the market but based
on another human being.
That's what I'd like people to learn,
which is like hey, what are we doing here?
You've won the four hundred
trillion to one lottery
of being a human being, do you really
wanna live with regret?
Do you not understand that the internet
is the greatest optionality
in the history of mankind?
That our grandparents
and everybody behind them
had nowhere close to the
options that you sit with today?
And really, what are you valuing
that's making you conform
into doing something
that doesn't make you happy,
your current overhead?
So sell your home and rent.
That sounds crazy, you know when I started
talking about hey, in
the pursuit of happiness,
would you consider selling
your home and renting?
I got destroyed in the comments sections
and a lot of the places like
that I'm some horrible person.
Like, how is living your
life to pay the bills
that you've created for yourself,
all that humans do are
create their own jails
and then live within it.
That's all we do, so knowing
that that's very hard
in a human way, the situation
that you have with your parents,
all that stuff, the professional one
feels like I have a prayer
of communicating that
and here's my point, if you
wanna be a professional skier
or you wanna start a blog
or podcast around cooking,
my big thing is, if you
jump and start swimming,
this is riding a bike, kissing
a boy or girl or swimming.
It seems super scary until you do it
and then you just laugh
about why it felt so scary.
If you go do that thing
and live more humble,
live with judgment, you
could always get a job again.
I don't know, my great fear is regret
because it is the obvious
thing I see in people
that are 80 to 100 years
old that seems super scary.
Nobody was thrilled that
they played it safe.
It's just, you don't see
it and I think people
should spend more time with
the 80 to 100 year olds
that aren't their grandparents.
(audience laughs)
I mean it, I mean it, people need context
on life a little bit.
I think people have a horrible
relationship with time.
Do you know how many people in this room
are scared shitless of 30, like
it's some, it means nothing.
But our society's decided to tell you
that you have to figure it out and marry
and children and what
are you talking about?
98% of the 59 year olds I know
don't have it figured out.
The hell are we supposed to
have it all figured at 30?
25, like people are
making terrible decisions,
getting married because they think
they're supposed to by this age.
Buying homes because they
think they're supposed to.
The rules of modern society have lead to,
everybody wants to blame technology
and drug companies for all our problems.
We need to blame our
norms, our expectations
our ridiculous north
stars that make no sense.
When I look at this young of a crowd,
they're living to 110.
There's an enormous
amount of people in here
that are gonna live to
110 and are freaking out
that they don't have it figured out by 30.
You're not even a fucking
quarter of the way there yet.
(audience laughs)
what are we talking about?
So, that's very heady stuff
in its practical layer
of business and life and jobs and career,
I think everybody owes it to themselves
to start something on the side
around something that
they're really, desperately.
The reason a lot of entrepreneurs
are alco, workaholics
(audience laughs)
there's a whole different
reason they're alcoholics.
Honestly, I'll just go
to that for a minute.
Entrepreneurship is super lonely,
I hate that entrepreneurship is cool now
'cause people that are not
entrepreneurs are jumping in
and it is a dangerous, lonely game.
If you're not a purebred,
you will get eaten up.
If you don't love losing
and love the struggle
and love the pushback, you will lose,
you will be unhappy but the reason
that a lot of entrepreneurs
are workaholics
is 'cause they love it, they got lucky.
They like literally love,
I remember not loving it.
Being in school, looking at the clock
from first period on,
one day in high school
feels longer than the
last decade of my life.
I mean that and I know
there's an enormous amount
of people here, at this right exact moment
that are already counting down Friday
and that's not good and
that's not good for Chase
and that's not good
for them and so we need
a better debate and it starts
with what we spend our money on.
A lot of people are "Gary but how am I
"supposed to live in New York City?"
I'm like, "Don't."
(audience laughs)
Like don't, we have to get
more binary around happiness.
I really believe that.
(ringtone)
Hey guys, sorry to interrupt your video.
I'm just giving you
this call from my number
to let you know that you have
to join my text community.
212-931-5731, hit me up with a text.
- I had the real pleasure
of getting to talk
to a lot of young people in
my job, here at this company
and I feel, even from
a entrepreneurial level
within the company that people
are afraid to take risks.
"Well I was a communications major,
"so therefore I have to go
on the communications path
and then I have to be a
more senior communicator".
We have a place name, JP Morgan Chase.
You can, like Mary said,
you can move to London,
you can move to Dubai and take a risk
but people are terrified,
how do you get that--
- Trish, people are in the business of no.
People are in the business
of saying, "no" before they asked.
People prefer to blame the machine.
I'm aware, I have it at Vayner.
I have a full, hardcore open-door policy
but some people would
rather go to the bathroom
and vent than actually talk to me,
when I've proven over the last half decade
how unbelievably safe it is to talk to me.
- So how do you do it?
How do you push yourself to take a risk?
- Practice.
- Hmm, what do you mean?
- I've been thinking a
lot about this lately.
I think you have to challenge yourself.
Listen, careers are, the
reason I talk so much
about work is, it's a scary
percentage of our entire life.
The amount of time you spend working
in comparison to everything else you do,
when you add sleeping into the equation,
it gets really intense.
So I really push people
here and how do you do it?
If it's too hard to do here
because you're a student
and you're in a machine
and now you're this, you have
to try to do things outside.
I actually think somebody
here, off of this talk,
who then goes and tries
skiing, I don't know why
I'm stuck on that today,
for the first time
and never was a skier, or
cooking, or going to an opera,
doing something completely uncomfortable
may start the process of them
doing something uncomfortable here.
I think it's practice,
I think you need to,
by the way, I like to go
literal once in a while.
I'm hoping one person does this.
Go volunteer at a nursing
home for one day in your life.
A, I think you'll get a lot of value
of what I talked about earlier,
'cause perspective is the game
and you can get it real quick
if you go into that jungle.
And B, that's you doing
something uncomfortable.
I think people have to break patterns.
I think you do something different
or build courage to do something different
by getting used to it.
The great fortune of my
life was I was an immigrant
who got picked on for not
being able to speak English.
I was a terrible student,
I was not good at sports.
I basically lived the
first 18 years of my life
telling me that I was a losing player.
So I got real cozy with losing.
I loved losing, it's why I associate
so much more with people that
don't come from privilege.
Whether they look that part and look,
I view privilege first and foremost,
we don't have, we can see a
white male looks privileged.
We can see somebody who's well
off financially as privilege.
The real privilege game in our society
is what's going on in everybody's dome.
Mental privilege is number one.
This is why I talk so
much about parenting.
We're living through the worst execution
of parenting in our society
because we're living through
such enormous success,
abundance and prosperity in
America for the last 67 years
and so now parents are
getting into things.
You know, parents during
the great depression
struggled with going to school
and yelling at the teacher
for not doing this,
that or the other thing.
So we're living in eighth place trophies,
fake environments, entitlement.
There are kids in this room right now
who take money from their parents
and are over the age of 22.
I believe that that is the
number one poison in our society.
I believe it creates
enormous fake environments.
It subconsciously tells children
that they're not capable and
they need their parents help
and fake environments are bad
and it leads to bad behavior.
Do you know that our society
doesn't talk about saving money at all?
We don't talk about saving money at all.
We don't talk about borrowing
money from our parents
and paying them back, that's what
two generations ago used to do.
Now we just, we're so fucking
entitled, we just expect.
Everybody always asks me,
"Hey, how do I manage these millennials?"
I'm like, "With empathy."
they were parented in an environment
where if you came in ninth,
they clapped for you.
(audience laughs)
listen, I think this is a
super important subject matter.
I'm not saying boo somebody
and make them feel like,
I'm a product of self-esteem.
My Mom did the greatest job of self-esteem
but she also created accountability.
And we really need to debate that.
- So you have kids.
- Yup.
- A little bit older.
- 10 and seven.
- 10 and seven, okay,
so I know so many kids
as a Mom of teenagers who are struggling
with the existing classroom
format of you have to go class
for 45 minutes and take
English and then math
and then science and they're struggling
and it feels like it's a
broken education system,
relative to where the world is moving
and this entrepreneurial spirit,
yet they still have no
choice but to go through it.
So what advice do you give your kids?
- Listen, I'm a hardcore D and F student,
so I'm not interested in hypocrisy.
My daughter who's 10 looks
like she's a big time student.
I think she studied more yesterday
than I did in my entire career.
(audience laughs)
And that's awesome, I have no
interest in frowning on that.
I think that's great and as
long as that makes her happy
and we have proper
conversations around that,
I don't think my son's
gonna go exactly that route
but for me, it's not about
demonizing the system.
It's about having a 360 conversation.
I have no interest in my
children being entrepreneurs.
If they happen to have that DNA
and that makes them, the only thing
I want my kids to do is be as
happy as I am in what they do.
If they look at my and look,
now there's a new variable.
Things with me continue to
grow, I'm very empathetic
but they may look at it and be like,
"I don't want any part of that".
And I'm gonna go to Peru and
give away all his money, right?
And I'm good with that.
(audience laughs)
I really am, I'm really good with that.
I really, really just want
them to find their thing
and if their thing is something
that I am maybe not as passionate about,
which is be more within the system,
create less risk, my kids could say,
"You know what, I hate entrepreneurship,
"it made Dad travel a lot, I hate it."
that makes sense to me
and so my communication
with my children is more about them
truly looking for their happiness
and understanding the world will evolve
quite a bit by the time
they hit the real world
and leaning into the
happiness but practically.
You wanna go paint with tomatoes in Peru?
That's amazing, just FYI, I'm
not giving you one dollar.
And that's amazing, like
to me if they're gonna live
with four friends in a commune,
that's tremendous, that's awesome.
To me, it's just about
merit and happiness.
Practical optimism.
- So this is a early in career
audience that you've got here.
What is some practical actual advice
that they could take away and
how are they gonna advance
themselves, advance their careers
from a personal branding perspective?
Something they'd walk out of
the room and do immediately.
- So my number, number
one thing that I think
may be very unique and
couldn't be more passionate
in delivering to this
audience is the following.
I really highly recommend that
you die on your own sword.
Let me explain what I mean by that.
Every day, a lot of you are in meetings
where things are being talked about
that you may have some insights, opinions
and actual knowledge about and you are not
communicating an opposing view
because you know that it won't be accepted
by the managers above you
and you think it's a
vulnerability by communicating it.
And I think it's the reverse.
I think there's an incredibly soft
and respectful way for
you to create a data point
to the conversation and that I believe
this is what I see a lot happening,
where people don't say anything,
'cause they're appeasing how to move up,
manager to manager to manager.
The world actually changes
and then the company resets
and the executive, by
not saying something,
gets viewed upon as, that
was their point of view
and they get hurt by
pandering to the machine,
versus by being historically
correct in the room.
When all those executives either grow
within the organization or
disperse to other organizations,
they become an interesting
prospect to bring along,
because they were historically correct.
I'm giving advice that I
take as an entrepreneur.
My businesses are always much slower
and smaller upfront because I'm often
talking about and executing on something
that hasn't been accepted
in the macro yet.
And all the upside is on the back end.
I think people in here are sitting
on their words and they
shouldn't and everybody knows it.
This entire room is in meetings every day
where we talk about things
that they don't agree with
and they don't say a single word.
I don't think you should
say 'em the way I do
(audience laughs)
I say them aggressively in my Jersey style
because I have nobody who can fire me.
(audience laughs)
I mean that, the client can fire me
and that would be my
fault but I understand
why executives can't do what I do.
But if I was a senior executive
or my first day intern, knowing
my communication style of DNA,
I would just do it very politely and soft
but I would say look, I
don't think banner ads,
even though the data shows
that it's doing well,
I think we're only looking
at short term conversions
and not factoring in LTV
and it has decline in CAC
and what's the value of that customer.
I would share my thoughts.
The key that I notice is,
but you have to know what
you're talking about.
Where a lot of people get caught
is they think they know
what they're talking about
and then they say something
and they're wrong.
One of the things that's
super interesting to me
is I talk about a very narrow thing.
I stay very narrow, I'm just
not interested in being wrong.
So I actually stay quiet
for all the talking I do,
I'm quiet around 99.9% of things.
It's why I don't get involved
in a lot of other subject matters.
I could talk about marketing, I could talk
about the Jet's offense line woes
(audience laughs)
I could talk about wine
but I keep it narrow
'cause I don't know about healthcare.
- But you probably have an opinion.
- That's for sure, every one of us does
but that's not the kind of thing
that I would stake in the
ground for career advancement.
- So you do know a lot about wine,
so tell us, what's your
favorite Sauvignon Blanc
and your favorite cab?
- My favorite Sauvignon Blancs tend to be
from the Sancerre region in France,
because I tend to like
stoney, flinty flavors
more than the grass that
you get from New Zealand
and I think California
Sauvignon Blanc sucks.
(audience laughs)
So, Sancerre, Lucien
Crochet is a great producer,
so I would say that and then on cab,
I think cab is the most
overpriced wine in the world.
It became very popular,
I think Napa Valley cabs
are wildly overpriced, so for Cabernet,
maybe a Bordeaux based cab from the Medoc
because I tend to like a little more
vegetal and nuanced flavors.
And by the way, it's similar to media.
It's not that I hate
television commercials,
I just think there's better alternatives.
If you love Cabernet and
I'm sure 90% of the people
that like red wine like
to some degree to love it,
I just know that there's
alternatives in Portugal,
alternatives in Argentina that can appease
your big fruit, silky,
creamy, oaky flavors
for a third of the price.
It's never about anything
other than arbitrage for me.
So it's not that Napa cabs
suck or Cabernet sucks,
it's that you're paying for the brand
of Napa cab and you're
not educated to know
that you can get that fulfillment
from the Priorat in Spain.
(audience laughs)
- Okay, one more question--
- And by the way, on that note,
just to make a segue to some
of the stuff I talk about,
that is absolutely my thesis in marketing.
I don't hate direct mail, you can show me
direct mail that works, I just don't know
that you've perfectly
executed one mile radius
Facebook ads with contextual creative
to the person that's seeing it.
That's all.
- How did your wine business
lead to VaynerMedia.
- That, when I had the
awakening at 34 of like,
wait a minute, I'm not a great retailer,
I'm a great communicator,
I built this business
from three to 60 million
dollars with no money
because I was right about
eCommerce, I was right
about email, I was right
about Google AdWords.
I was right about YouTube,
I was right about Twitter.
All five things I just told
you, you guys are youngsters.
When I started winelibrary.com in 1996,
people told me the internet
was a fad, the whole thing.
Forget about Snapchat or Vine
or TikTok, the whole thing.
People that sold the Yellow Pages
in a chamber of commerce
event made fun of me,
like, this kid's, he's gonna be wrong.
Like he doesn't know, he's a child.
And I was like, "The
consumer's always right".
I don't even feel like I'm a human being.
All I think I am is a pass-through
to what humans are actually doing.
I'm not right about TikTok,
humans are doing it.
There's hundreds of
millions of people using it.
This is not prediction
time, this happened.
I love people like, what's next,
you're Nostradamus, you predict.
I'm like, I'm a post-game newscaster.
(audience laughs)
I'm not Nostradamus,
I'm like Howard Cosell.
This happened, podcasting happened.
- He was a newscaster.
(audience laughs)
- LinkedIn happened, I've never
predicted a thing in my life,
I'm just not scared to execute
on what's actually happening,
'cause I'm not in the
business of making reports
or politics my north star.
- Why don't we open it up to the crowd?
- Let's go.
- You probably need a mic
so that the people watching
the webcast can hear you.
- And there's one over there for next.
- How are you?
- [Audience Member] Hey
Gary I'm doing well.
My name's Dave Davis, how you doin' man.
I have a question, so I'm
a father, I'm 29 years old.
I have a four year old and my question
pertains to, I want her to be safe,
I wanna try to some degree help make sure
she doesn't really get off track
and provide her best school,
best things like that.
But I know that you
mentioned your philosophy
on your children and just
wanna get your advice
from a parent perspective, right?
When do you kinda say--
- I got it, look, first of all.
My interest in giving any specific person
parenting advice, is 0.0, I
think everybody needs to parent
the way they decide to parent.
I like communicating the alternatives
to what I think is being accepted,
especially no different
than TikTok happened.
I, Gary Vaynerchuk, get
over a thousand DMs a week
on Instagram from kids
that are deeply resentful
of their parents for
over-manipulating their lives.
I'm talking about, I hate my parents
'cause they pay for my Equinox and Uber.
(audience laughs)
I reply and say, "Then stop
taking the money, dick".
(audience laughs)
But I also know what's
going on at a higher level.
Which is parents are using their children
as products to impress
their contemporaries.
The reason parents pay is not necessarily
because they wanna help
the kid, it's they want
their friend, their sister, their parents
or others to think little
Johnny and Sally are successful.
So you need to do you but let me say this.
I don't understand why people
can't remember them being kids.
I love parents that are
like, "I restrict my kids
"time on their phone", I'm
like, "They've seen porn".
Like this notion that we can
control life is laughable
and more importantly, we're
giving indicators to kids
that we don't trust them,
which creates self doubt
which really leads to
a lot of unhappiness.
So look, you get to pick your north star.
My north star is self-esteem
and accountability and happiness.
Not Harvard, not entrepreneurship,
not winning, that.
I want them to be happy, big time.
I want them to be accountable.
I'll never forget, I was a
really good baseball player
in third and fourth grade,
before talent kicked in
and this one kid, John
Longo was a real pitcher,
big fat Italian kid,
if you're watching John
(audience laughs)
and because he was so
big, he could throw gas
and he just overpowered me and I went 0-4
and struck out four
times, which is unheard of
because I was really at my apex then.
And I just remember my Mom coming in
and I came in and starting
looking for excuses
like I should've batted fourth today,
it was sunny, she was like
"You struck out four times".
Meanwhile, this is the woman
who, when I opened the door
for an elderly woman at
McDonald's once, treated it
as a Nobel Prize winning award behavior.
So she created enormous self-esteem
but not delusion, right?
Listen, if you're five foot four
and your parents are telling you,
"Yes, you can go to the
NBA, Abraham" that's fine
(audience laughs)
but it needs to be added
with "and you will be one
"of the only three people
in the history of the sport"
and oh by the way, Muggsy
Bogues and Spud Webb
could do all these other things
that you are showing that you cannot.
(audience laughs)
This, you can be anything delusion
is what's leading to a lot of resentment
and pushback and so I would just tell you
that delusion and more importantly
what you put on a north
star today will change.
Look, college is under siege.
There's gonna be seven or eight colleges
with enough brand equity in fifteen years
to maintain their spot
but the rest of them
are in real trouble.
I'm 43 and I was making $5,000 a weekend
selling baseball cards
as 12, 13, 14 year old
and was considered a loser.
Today, I'm in the Wall Street Journal
'cause entrepreneurship is cool.
Back then, if you didn't
go to a great college,
you had no chance of happiness or success.
By the time your kid in 14 years
enters the time to go into school
or in 18 years comes out of it,
I have a funny feeling that
the rules will be different.
So keep that in mind.
- [Audience Member] Thank
you, hi, good afternoon.
Thank you so much and I
just wanna say thank you
for introducing over
and over and over again,
happiness because I think people forget
when you're supposed to
have this planned out,
this school, all these things on paper,
they forget what it is
to actually be happy.
So I'm really--
- And, and I apologize and you decide.
You decide what that is.
Not me, not the game,
not your parents, you.
Which is what gets me into process.
Why do I want people to do what they love?
Because if your chasing
something for affirmation,
you're in trouble.
I don't want the trophies,
I don't want the
accolades, I want the game.
- [Audience Member] So my
question to you is this.
In the universe of
self-branding and social media,
you produce a lot of
content and it's meaningful
because I've been on binges
where I watched your videos.
Okay, so that'll happen while we're here.
So for me, I would like
to know your thoughts
on if you're building your brand,
what's a good starting
point to introduce yourself.
- The truth, the truth.
- [Audience Member] The truth?
- The truth, the truth is undefeated.
That's it and people
are scared of the truth.
That's the only advantage you have.
There's so much content
being produced today,
the only way you actually
can break through
is your unique truth, it's just true.
There's just a volume of
creative and consumption
that we've never seen before,
so that to build, you've gotta
lean into your uniqueness.
My truth of baseball
cards and flea marketing
and root beer and the Jets and wine,
those are the unique
things that make me feel
a little bit different than others.
It's also a lot easier to produce content
when you don't have to think.
My friends, it's a lot
easier to produce content
when you don't have to think.
- [Audience Member]
Document, don't create.
- That's right and the reason I brought up
document and don't create is
I'm not scared of my truth.
My strengths, my weaknesses, it's not fun
when you're actively the CEO
of a thousand person company
to actively always constantly
talk about struggling
with radical candor, knowing
your employee sees that
and then they're sitting in front of you
and you're dancing around.
The last scene of Eminem,
"8 Mile" last scene,
most important scene in
movie history, I believe it.
(audience laughs)
In that battle rap, by
him exposing himself,
he left nothing for the opposing party.
The most unhappiness you will ever have
is the secret you're hiding,
because you don't want
anybody to have that leverage.
Once you let it go, you become
fundamentally unstoppable.
- [Audience Member] Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
Let's go to that lady first.
We'll go to this gentleman next.
- [Audience Member] Hi Gary,
I work closely with Trish
supporting our thinking
and (speaks faintly)
- Awesome.
- [Audience Member] I'm
a huge fan of the Resy
restaurant app, I know
you're one of the founders.
- I am.
- [Audience Member] So
I'm just interested in
understanding better how do you decide
which company you wanna
invest in, on support
and how do you decide which
industry you wanna get into.
I know you work with
wine, restaurants, media
on social media, so just elaborate
a little bit more about that.
- Thank you, so it's really serendipity.
I started a fund at the
same time that my friend
Ben leventhal was just
leaving his current gig.
We had dinner one night and he's like
"I have good news, eater
just got sold to Vox"
and I'm like, "I have good
news, I'm starting a fund".
We're like, maybe we should
do something together
and literally during that
dinner, we were like,
you know, maybe what Uber did for taxis,
we can do for the supply and
demand of restaurant seats
and that was our opening thesis, which was
why don't restaurant
seats sell like airlines
more than just like the same price.
There was no supply and demand metric.
Ultimately, that's not what Resy became.
What we learned after 24 months was,
open table's not that
good, so let's just go
right at that, that's what we did
and that's what eventually lead (coughs)
excuse me, to it's great success
and the enormous exit we had
recently and so, serendipity.
I'm a counter puncher, I'm
much more Floyd Mayweather
than Mike Tyson, I don't wake up
and I'm like, I'm gonna go kill that.
I'm more living, living,
listening, listening.
I'm like oh, sports agency too.
As much passion as I have to buy the Jets,
I never viewed it as, I'm gonna start
a Jerry Maguire like business
and then buy the Jets.
But then when I started
looking and hearing,
I'm like oh, this industry
could be disrupted.
So I spent a lot of time listening.
I always say that to people that follow me
who are most hardcore, every second
you don't see me, I'm listening.
It's why I love Q&A,
it's why I read my DMs.
It's why I started my text platform,
because people feel even
more comfortable telling me.
I want the truth, right?
That's where the real stuff is.
I would've never gotten into parenting,
I came from my parents giving me nothing.
Even when I said people complaining
about their parents paying,
you should've seen everybody's face here,
like "Fuck, I wish my
parents paid for me", right?
(audience laughs)
I would've never known that,
I would have never known
what kind of sadness
people that were getting
subsidized would actually feel.
We don't have empathy for
other people's problems.
We think our problem is the problem.
And so, a lot of listening
and that's what my next
businesses will be,
they'll be because I've listened,
did a little homework, see the blood
in the water, shark it up.
(audience laughs)
- [Audience Member] Hi Gary, thanks
for being with us here today.
- Thanks for having me.
- [Audience Member] So I'm
here, I'm next to my wife today.
She's an executive director
of a nonprofit called CULIKID, available
to children, teens,
adolescents with special needs
and it's a culinary program.
So during grassroots, she
about a year and a half ago
she quit her job, founded
this organization,
brought her program to
them and now she's in,
she's become the executive director.
It's a great opportunity,
she's very happy,
how much she can talk about.
So the problem that we're having
and I say "We" because I support her is,
how do we, when we apply for grants
and foundations, things
like that and donations,
how do we, without having
the right track record
of five, 10 years, a lot
of these organizations
already have, who will they donate to,
things like that, how do
we grab their attention
with meaningful content,
documenting things that we're doing
and hopefully, we can
change the conversation
around--
- By doing that, you listen
to the way you just said it.
The fact that you know that
it's content, which it is.
Communication is how everything happens.
Documenting it, which you understand.
It's kind of like you saying,
"How do I get healthier?"
I know I have to eat better
and work out every day
but how do I really do it Gary?
I'm like, by eating better
and working out every day.
You're talking about a lack of patience.
No nonprofit that has no
awareness and didn't exist
should be getting an
overflow of donations.
That's not how it works,
you need to put out content.
You need to devalue the production value
and upvalue the output and that's it.
Now the tactics of, do you want ads
against high net worth individuals
on the upper west side, yes.
You fish where the fish are
but it's just making content
and making sure it's seen.
Whether you have no money
and have to go organic,
LinkedIn and Tiktok or
whether you do have money
and all of a sudden,
Facebook, pre-roll YouTube,
Instagram story swipe up
ads become your framework?
That's the game, rinse and repeat.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Who's got questions, there's
two gentlemen up here,
there's a young lady right there.
Let's go right down.
You'll go to her next?
- [Host] Yeah.
It's you bro, yeah, congrats.
(audience laughs)
How are you?
- [Audience Member] I
just wanted to thank you
for being raw, real and honest.
I really appreciate that,
that's why I follow you.
So my name's (speaker
coughs), I work in digital
account opening I just graduated
from Seton Hall, go Pirates.
I'm in a lot of meetings every day.
I mean six to eighteen a day
and sometimes I'm not always the one
that's effective in the meetings,
like I don't need to be there.
- Yes.
- [Audience Member] Sometimes
I do get to run them.
Now when I run meetings, I see two ways
that people do it, one is to not distract
and come in with an
agenda (speaks faintly).
And second, is in
creating (speaks faintly).
- Yes, yes, yes.
- [Audience Member] So I was wondering,
what is your favorite
thing about meetings?
- To make them way less long.
(audience laughs)
But to answer your question, both.
I think it's important to
have a Swiss army knife.
To your point, sometimes
I'm going into the meeting
because I need more context
and then I'll go creative.
And sometimes I'm trying
to deliver something
and I'll go more tactical.
I think they both work, I just think
they all run way too long,
there's not a single meeting
that anybody in this room has been on
that wasn't too long,
I fully believe that.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Audience Member] Hey Gary.
- How are you?
- I'm good.
- Good.
- [Audience Member] I'm a big fan.
So in creating all the
content that you create
and speaking your truth,
have you ever thought
about creating your own reality TV show?
- No but I do think the vlog
has a little bit of that.
Obviously, you probably know this.
I'm quite private, I share nothing
about my family or personal life.
First of all, I would never let a network
have that much control or economic upside,
knowing the world that I live in
but even then, I have too
much empathy for them,
because they would want
all the other stuff
and that's just a line
I'm not willing to cross.
So no but I definitely think the vlog
and what we do with DailyVee
gets into the nuances of it.
That I enjoy the ability
to control the narrative
and not do hellacious
things for Nielsen ratings.
Listen, I am never, ever
going to be part of a machine
that I don't control, because
it doesn't sound interesting
to me and that's why
I would never do that.
Got two over here, one back there.
- Mike?
- Yeah, you two can, I have no preference
of who gets the question,
just as many as possible.
- [Audience Member] Hi Gary.
- Hi.
- [Noah] I'm Noah Banks.
- Hey Noah.
- [Noah] I wanna say first off, thank you
for airing your content
coming up two years ago
and I actually used to vlog
the stuff that you taught
for us outside work hours
and then inside work.
I suggested everybody follow
you, there's a lot of stuff
you can actually apply to the job here.
(Trish applauds)
The question I do have is, the
one thing I do struggle with
actually, I didn't talk about--
- Yes.
- [Noah] Idea of focusing on
one thing, you know that book
came out everyone was
like, focus on one thing,
develop that one skill
versus also where I feel
like I kind of am right,
have a lot of interests,
where I wanna dive into
a lot of different things
but sometimes I feel bad
about it because like hey,
I don't know if that's the right path.
So what is your opinion on
sticking to one thing, or--
- I'm fundamentally the byproduct
of not sticking to one thing.
I'm in the business of
trying to juggle 50 balls
and knowing 13 of them will fall
and being thrilled about that,
because I have 37 balls in the air.
Because if I had one ball in the air,
I'd wanna call it quits and I think
you should do what you wanna do.
- [Audience Member] I put a lot of content
on the Calvin Fitness on LinkedIn,
I'd love for you to check
it out, see what you think.
(audience laughs)
- I will, Noah Banks.
Such a good fucking name.
(audience laughs)
I will yeah but bro and
this is for everybody,
this will always happen.
There are fundamentally,
it's very historically true,
there's the black and
white way and the gray way.
And things that ebb and flow,
they have their moments.
I don't even know what
book you're talking about,
focus on one thing but it has its moment.
And then next week, some young
lady's gonna put out a book
called, "Do 64 things" and
it will have its moment.
This is a self-awareness game.
I'm not right, I'm just
comfortable doing me.
I'm just hopeful you can do that too.
There is no right, you wanna be type A,
cross every T, make 700
lists a day, amazing.
Just make sure that you're doing it
because that's how you like it, right?
That's it, there is only the way,
you will always win when you
lean into your natural upside.
Our society is built to
sell you on closing the gap
on your weaknesses, all the upside
is tripling down on your strengths.
- [Audience Member] Hey Gary.
- How are you?
- [Audience Member] James.
- James.
- [Audience Member] (speaks faintly)
- I love it.
- [Audience Member] Just had a
quick question about failure.
- Yes.
- [Audience Member]
What would you consider
is your biggest failure and
what did you learn from it?
- Jeez, I think my biggest
failure was working
every minute of my 20s and
when I say every minute,
I mean all of them, like
no weekends, no friends.
I was just too hungry, it's
why I've always liked Koby.
It almost feels like it's a
little evil and dangerous.
I'm like, I get that.
I went too far, balance matters
and I think I resent and
regret and I really don't,
which is why I even took a pause
but I think the biggest
thing I learned about that
is it wouldn't have killed me
to go out a couple of Friday nights.
So I think I'm more balanced
at 43 than I was at 23
but bro, I'm gonna tell you something.
I'm really trying to
manifest an answer for you.
It's unbelievable how much practice I have
on the inability to dwell.
You know, I passed on Uber
twice on the angel round
from one of the people that
I was best friends with
while investing in a bunch of other things
and that $50,000 investment would be worth
$900 million dollars.
That was a mistake.
(audience laughs)
you know, there's so many mistakes.
I make a mistake every day of my life.
Like a lot of them, especially now
where I'm crippled by opportunity.
Every day, I'm fundamentally
sure of the following sentence:
every day I'm making pretty big mistakes
because I'm saying no to something
that could have lead to the big thing
of happiness or success.
I'm just not crippled by that.
I just don't understand why
people spend time on that.
Do you know any people
that are in college debt
spend 80% of their
downtime being resentful
that they took on debt for something
they'd come to realize didn't
bring them as much value in return?
The problem is, it's over.
If they took all that time, garage saling
and going to TJ Maxx and flipping,
they could start chipping
away at the debt.
TJ Maxx is loaded with arbitrage.
(audience laughs)
It is, you got to TJ Maxx, spend $1,000
and make $4,000 on eBay and
Amazon every day of the week.
But instead of making that
$3,000 of putting in work
instead of watching Netflix
or going to do something else,
people would rather sit and complain.
People would rather sit in
a bar on a Friday afternoon
buying $18 cocktail and complain
that they're in college debt
than do what I just said.
- [Audience Member]
You sound very eloquent
and you deliver on what you
say, so appreciate that.
- Nothing.
(audience laughs)
I've just lived, I actually
think that's the answer.
I believe that a lot of people
over correct with tutoring.
I believe that humans, especially today,
are making mountains out of molehills.
I'm sure my team that's
here will tell you,
the company wide emails that I send
or the things I read in Slack
have no grammar structure whatsoever.
I don't even think grammar
structure's a word.
(audience laughs)
Like nothing bro, you know why?
I don't give a shit what they
think of how I'm talking.
They're are people right
now that didn't like
that I cursed four times during this talk
and decided not to hear
everything I just talked about.
I can't control that.
(audience laughs)
I can't and more importantly,
I bring this up now
in the meta because if
you're one of those people
on simulcast or in this room,
if that's what you're deciding
to focus on, there's a real problem.
There's a real problem.
In life, you find what you're looking for.
In today's climate, in society,
I promise you the following.
You wanna find a lot of negativity?
It's very easy, on the flip side,
a much more unpopular
opinion is if you wanna find
a lot of happiness and opportunity,
you can find it very easily, you decide.
(audience applauds)